you met Trump recently is that right at
Donald Trump just a true story yes or is
this one of your he has a farm and a
goat come five
I saw triad he said I want you to meet
my donkey he said nice I quote mr. Trump
I know you're running for president but
tell me more about this here donkey well
he says if you want to see the donkey
you gotta first meet my three daughters
and the first ones shy the second one
sexy and the third one has one leg I'm
making all of this up no but this is
exactly what you do at the end I never
tell that type of joke because that's
that kind of a joke that we shouldn't be
telling you're right I apologize but I
will know I did we try you make this is
true you made absolutely true story I
was on another talk show not a competing
tax Locos Tacos don't hey and I think no
show competes with this one no sir
you say that with irony but I say that
with truth I agree with you you've been
on the air
23 years yeah my god mr. Kay seven years
shy of Carson himself
can you imagine Carson Daly Carson Dick
Grayson Bailey's been on 45 years but
look at this man
compared to Johnny Carson at the time
look at Johnny Carson get a picture of
him seven years before he retired long
white hair white beard Johnny always
looks fantastic well have I ever done my
Johnny Carson impression for you no you
haven't
I'm sure this young audience would love
to see it
[Music]
[Music]
this is you can you can play a lot you
can be the 911 operator this is Johnny
Carson when he was having as a heart
attack he actually put 9-1-1 people
don't know this
he found 9-1-1 himself he's a very brave
man and so during a heart attack he
phoned 9-1-1 so you be the 911 operator
okay say hello hello hello this is
Johnny Carson Oh mr. Carson how can I
help you I feel like there's a yak on my
chest well sir I'm gonna hang up on you
now now I shouldn't say stuff like that
yeah you met Trump
I just might give you trouble I guess I
feel as a closeted gay man living in a
deeply oh I got sham of a marriage I
have the right to say more but I guess I
don't mr. Trump is the true story yes we
were on a talk show not as good as your
talk show he was on first I was on
second there was only three minutes
between he stepped out Secret Service
was everywhere he knows me I've met him
and I said mr. Trump could I get a
picture he goes oh you're funny I love
you yeah just take a picture with you in
a minute and then he turned around and
he walked down with the Secret Service
guy I got an olive ate Buster Keaton
film
you